very very empirical science and so the
question is how do we how do we do
better empirical science of deep
learning and this obviously is about
eventually informing our theoretical
understanding and as well as our ability
to sort of engineer these kinds of
systems better one of the perspectives
on this that I feel like I got from from
David you know when he was in my lab
along with with my student Dougal
Maclaurin is the idea of building
microscopes so in other fields like
physics and biology if you have like a
deep empirical question there's a system
you want to understand better then you
are heavily motivated to build a way to
analyze that system better you're built
you know literally build a microscope
literally figure out a new way to
perform an assay or build a telescope to
look at some remote object you care
about and invent new sort of
instrumentation and I feel like it's
really helpful to frame some of the
problems we ask about our systems in
terms of building microscopes okay and
so the microscope that I want to sort of
tell you about today is a microscope for
very very large matrices and the reason
this is an interesting microscope to
build is because we care about the
spectra of really big matrices about the
eigenvalues of them for a variety of
different problems in the case of deep
learning we want to ask questions about
about the the Hessian of the
optimization problem right so we maybe
you have a neural network that's going
to have like tens of billions of
parameters in it right huge parameter
spaces and we want a reason about how
hard that optimization problem was how
many different solutions there are how
the hell are these things like ever
optimizable given how non-convex they
are like there's a lot of questions we
don't you actually don't understand
empirically where we can study things at
kind of small scale and david has done
some of this as well thinking about
thinking about you know using sort of
tiny little problems where you can maybe
compute the Hessian analytically and do
sort of diagonalization on it but how do
we actually examine these very very
large how do we sort of very very large
systems that we actually see in practice
and this is a lot harder because we
can't just diagonalize you know a 10
billion by 10 billion matrix right we
can't even represent it much less do
some sort of cubic algorithm on
so we want to be able to tackle these
kinds of problems and understand you
know where the saddle points like are we
really getting to minima how sensitive
are these problems to their parameters
and so on these are properties of the
eigenvalues but we also want to ask we
might also ask questions about very big
graphs as a sort of you know whether
there's this entire area spectral graph
theory we have giant graphs really big
adjacency matrices laplacian and we want
to be able to interrogate those to ask
questions about conductance or how the
number of triangles number of
communities and so on and this kind of
thing also arises in like many body
systems so one thing that is sort of
near and dear to my heart is using
machine learning to tackle computational
chemistry problems and there we're often
dealing with its density functional
theory and approximations to it that
involve inevitably sort of reasoning
again about very very large very large
matrices where the eigenvalues have
specific sort of physical
interpretations okay so that's what I
want to talk about today and I'm going
to and what I'm going to do is tell you
about ways to tackle this problem by
telling you about two tricks so that I
think are totally awesome from different
communities from the late 1980s and then
we're going to plug those together and
kind of twist it up just a little bit to
wind up with unbiased estimates of
different interesting things you might
want to know about really big matrices
and I'm going to call these implicit
matrices implicit matrices are where you
can't represent it all you can do is
interrogate it via matrix vector
products and in fact in the case of deep
learning you probably can't even
actually do a matrix vector product you
can just get an unbiased estimate of a
matrix vector product because you're
going to have you're going to have some
mini batch type situation right but you
can also think about large-scale
algorithms for sparse graphs and how
those would let you do these kinds of
products because it's kind of an
edgewise operation but you're not going
to be able to build this this big matrix
explicitly okay so that's kind of the
name of the game here is thinking about
really big matrices so let me just kind
of write that here so we're carrying
about some big matrix a and all we can
do is choose some to some vector that
we're going to multiply this guy by and
so we can look at we can look at vectors
like that for some X that we get to
choose and maybe we only get an unbiased
estimate of that thing and it's hard
because
we can't represent a and we can't and in
it may be the case that we only again
get sort of mini batch type type
estimates so the first trick I'm going
to tell you about is what's called the
randomized trace estimator okay so the
lens I'm going to sort of use for this
is the idea that if we can we're called
sort of generalized traces we can answer
a lot of the questions we'd like to be
able to ask about really big matrices so
that is I'm going to talk about
quantities where we're going to take the
trace of some matrix function applied to
the matrix a alright so if F is like a
matrix log then this gives us an
estimate of the log determinant but we
can think about other kinds of things as
well so the functions we'll talk about
for apps are going to be basically
functions of the eigenvalues and so we
could imagine thinking about other kinds
of things like indicator functions or
sort of asking questions about the
moments of the spectral density and
other kinds of things where you apply a
function to all the eigenvalues and then
sum them right and this is kind of what
we're going to be what we're going to be
doing here and we're going to wind up
with unbiased estimate so these are
these kinds of things that's the that's
the name of the game okay so two tricks
that I think are awesome and that
everyone should know about the first is
a randomized trace estimator
yeah let's just for like let's just
assume that that these are that these
are symmetric matrices they don't
necessarily have to be positive definite
because sometimes we're going to want to
ask questions about things that negative
eigenvalues what's that yes yes they are
real some of the things I'll talk about
would generalize but in general machine
learners don't care about complex
numbers it appears so all right so
here's here's a very cool little trick
which is that if we take if we have some
matrix a and we generate a vector X
that's from just like a spherical model
this row mean any covariance and then we
form a quadratic form
the expectation of that is the trace of
a
raise your hand if you are going do that
okay cool so the this is pretty easy to
prove because you can just read you can
just sort of apply the usual kind of
like trace trick type things so if we
think about what this would be we're
going to have a we can always write this
when we have scalars we can always write
this guy like that right
this trace of a scalar and then we can
apply everyone's favorite our mutation
trick right to the trace so we can do
this thing right where we rotate we sort
of swing things around and then because
race is linear we can write trace of the
expectation
and then a pops out right because it's
it's a because it's not random
and we have chosen this guy such that
this is the identity right so then we
just wind up with trace of a
I've showed you this because it also
reveals that there's a much more general
class of axes for this for which this
would work in particular Rademacher
random variables and anything that has
the property that this center that this
outer product of the random variables is
identity okay so that if that's true
then you're in business and and so this
is a really cool trick it means that if
we have some big matrix a and we can
access it in this sort of indirect way
then we can we can estimate its trace
now traces don't sound that hard but
actually they're still kind of hard to
get to for for like really big neat deep
neural networks and things one of the
things that's really cool and by the way
this is I think generally attributed to
Hutchinson in 1989 but then there's been
kind of it's been used in a variety of
other ways since then the one of the
things that's really cool about this is
that it has a blessing of dimensionality
so we all curses the dimensionality
usually but in this case the bigger the
a is the faster this is going to
converge central limit theorem
essentially because it's just going to
hit more stuff whenever you're summing
over more things whenever you whenever
you do this do this little estimator and
so so this is kind of the first the
first trick and there's some nice
theoretical work on bounding this and
Rademacher variables are a little bit
better than than gaussians and but you
could imagine kind of general classes of
this and so on in the case of gaussians
you can also reason about in a different
way by just thinking about if a is
diagonalizable then you would have this
kind of like rotation diagonal rotation
and hitting a spherical random variable
with the rotation so has the same
marginal and so then it's just hitting a
diagonal thing that doesn't work for the
Rademacher case but it's something that
kind of does kind of a useful thing to
know so that's trick number one yeah so
X transpose ax is cheap to calculate for
a realization today so once you have
done this right we get that thing and
now it's just an inner product with X
again I write so I'm assuming I'm
assuming that I can I can do that I can
do that if I can do that then I can I
can dot it with something else and
cheaply
it's like a super simple example where
you I'm just about to keep so so a super
simple example will be if you wanted to
estimate the log debt of something big
using kind of where this is gonna be
major clogged so hang around and I'll
show you how we're going to use we could
use this for really big things like
counting okay yeah right off yeah no
that's that's that's right that's right
yeah I mean I'm just saying in general
if these are kind of like yeah if this
is like a really kind of obnoxious
matrix then then or it has kind of like
one big value and buried in it somewhere
then then it's not necessarily the
victims bigger that's right I've got
about making assumption structural
assumptions about a being kind of like
dense I guess a bit like other questions
okay so that's trick number one really
cool trick number two
is from a completely different community
and it's called the placin estimator and
I'm guessing that on order of two people
in the room and heard of the Poisson
estimator before so this is kind of
attributed to I think this is attributed
to two vogner in like 1987 so again it's
kind of an older trick I learned about
it from reading a paper by a most
popular populace from like 2009 the and
it's also a problem that I feel like
when you sort of take undergrad
statistics you learn is impossible and
yet it turns out to not be to impossible
so here's the situation we have we have
a quantity let's say the quantity Y and
we have an estimator of Y let's call it
Y hat so we have some randomized
estimator
guy it has the nice property that it is
that it's unbiased okay unfortunately
we're not interested in why we're
interested and eetu the Y so what we
really want to know is something else
say Z
everybody knows that in general if I
just take my Y hat and X bit I'm not
going to get the right answer right so
it turns out though that for relatively
well-behaved functions in particular
analytic functions you can fix it up and
make an unbiased estimator for Z out of
unbiased estimators for y everybody
already know that yeah okay so here is
an example of how how to do this so the
reason it's called the Poisson estimator
is what we're going to do is we're going
to draw an integer okay from a Poisson
distribution
with some parameter that is just a free
parameter lambda alright and then what
we're going to do is we're going to form
a random implement a random product of a
bunch of white hats
so we're going to take it we're going to
write down an estimator Z hat there's
going to be equal to our e to the lambda
multiplied by a product of K Y hats so
these are independent Y hats drawn from
whatever our little estimator here is
okay so that's going to be this a random
quantity we get the expectation of that
is Z is e to the Y and it's unbiased so
I mean that's the definition of advice
so so this is a really cool little trick
and you can convince yourself of this by
just writing it out so if we just say
what's the expectation of this guy Z hat
right and if we remember that the
Poisson PMF is is lambda to the K
divided by K factorial times e to the
negative lambda so if we write this guy
out and we see that we get this sum I
want to say a sum over J equal to 0 to
infinity of this PMF
okay
so that's the probability that we get a
particular K and when we get a
particular K we do this product
one of the J of this guy right so Y hat
by by lambda oh sorry that's important
okay so what's going to happen if we
have a product of a bunch of independent
random variate s-- then that's just the
and the expectation is just is actually
the products or expectations and so
we're going to wind up being able to
rewrite this as same sum over j but now
we have lambda j a factorial now we're
going to get j of those guys right so
that's just going to be y to the y to
the j divided by lambda j so that
cancels out that cancels out now we get
this sum from J equals 0 to infinity of
y to the J divided by J factorial and we
should recognize that as the as the
power series for the exponential
function that's crazy right like how
could that possibly work well I mean it
doesn't really work but it does yeah I
have a data set I calculate y hat how do
I do this I don't get I don't get
multiple estimates like that yeah you
need to be able to get multiple
estimates of what yeah so if you if you
can construct a randomized estimator by
like subsampling data that's one way to
get it or maybe you have some maybe
you're the estimator is like some kind
of like other kind of estimator where
you get to generate the randomness so
maybe it's more like a randomized
algorithm and less like a data
subsampling thing the variance on this
could be kind of obnoxious people have
been excited about it recently for
exactly the reasons that David was just
talking about which is that if you know
we can get easy we can easily get
unbiased estimates of log likelihoods
and the question is once we have those
how would we fix them up to to get a
valid Markov chain Monte Carlo algorithm
this is one way you can imagine doing
that
you're focusing on the fire so what you
have like sort of air balance how does
that the central Atlanta okay so in this
case I'm using this as kind of an
example but really this trick is not a
is not the trick that I want to
emphasize it's that if we this is just
it turns out doing function approximate
randomize function approximation by
important sampling right so so let's
sort of generalize that a little bit and
then we can talk about specific cases
where we can bound it right we have this
knob we can turn to reduce the variance
with lambda but it can still be
obnoxious for all the reasons an
important assembling can be obnoxious so
more generally if we have an analytic
function right what that means is that
we have that if we have some function we
care about it just means that we're
going to be able to write it and
something that looks like this
and we could do other things as well we
could do like chebyshev polynomials and
so on and and so when we see something
like this even though this is kind of
like calculus 101 we might we sort of
put our light monte-carlo hat on we
could imagine actually important
sampling this guy right where we would
instead say let's form an F hat of X
where we have some proposal distribution
pie and now we're going to say now we're
going to say AJ we're going to draw an
integer from pi so pi is a distribution
now over the like the natural numbers
and we form an estimator like that and
just because it's important sampling
that'll be an unbiased estimate of our
function at X the variance may be a
disaster right depending on just like it
sort of always can be if we choose pi
poorly relative to relative to to the
sequence of a J's right but we can look
at like some specific cases like for
example we can look at like the you know
the natural log and there it's kind of
particularly obnoxious with a slowly
decaying tail but we can choose
distributions like the like the zeta
distribution that also have comparable
tails and then we can bound the variance
within the sort of radius of convergence
of the of the of the original series
basically okay so this is kind of just
all so even though this at least when I
first saw this this looks like magic to
me
right but it's just doing this with the
put with the exponential function and
the Poisson and a Poisson proposal
distribution yeah
listen to the simple conditional aging I
Jason make sure
there is unfortunately not a simple
condition that I have been able to
identify generally the kind of condition
that we would expect to guarantee it to
be well behaved is if is is basically if
the ratio here has some upper bound
right so that that is to say that you
never get into a situation where you
choose a really sort of deep J with
vanishingly small probability and it
blows up the result exactly like when
you're doing important sampling if your
proposal distribution has lighter tails
than the target then occasionally you're
going to wind up with giant weights and
you could have infinite variance so this
suffers from exactly the same
pathologies the good news is that it's
just the natural numbers and so if
you're doing this trick you're probably
able to interrogate the AIDS in a way
that maybe would be easier than then you
could in the end the sort of like
general inference case policy yeah yeah
yeah yeah it doesn't you can't do this
better than you could do this the point
is that you know you already know
something about convergence with these
guys okay so there's a few different
tricks that trick though what's
interesting about it is that we can
generalize it to the obnoxious term
which is sort of whole amorphic operator
calculus all that means is that you can
take this whole thing and do it for
matrices all right and and that is to
say if you have a function that you're
going to apply you're going to
generalize some analytic function that
you care about to matrices then
essentially what you do is write out the
power series in just the same way but
now you're going to raise you're going
to do matrix powers instead of scalar
powers and what's really nice about that
is that it turns out that all you're
doing when you do that is applying your
scalar function f to the eigenvalues of
the of the matrix believe me
we can kind of Reason about this by just
saying okay if I have some something I
care about a and I can diagonalize it
then I raised a to some power right then
if I raise it to you know say I square
it then I'm hitting this hitting it with
this guy again and these guys are just
the identity sort of like instruction
and so then this thing just boils off to
that and planta is diagonal so this is
just raising all those all those in
trees along the diagonal to that power
okay
so we can take this then and take our
favorite function f applied to matrices
and now we can important sample these
matrix valued functions or some analytic
function we care about so I think you
can kind of maybe see where I'm heading
with this right so now what we can do is
we can take this trick for expanding
into randomized power series so we're
just choosing one power and we can
combine that with this trick and we wind
up with an unbiased estimate for some F
and even if we have to do the kind of
slightly more complicated thing where we
generate these sort of randomized wise
from many batches say with a giant deep
neural network we can still we can still
push it through okay and because the
exes that we're using to do this part
are independent of the randomness we're
using to do this part then you can
convince yourself that you'll wind up
with with unbiased estimates of the
overall thing okay so that's kind of the
main so that's why saying it's a couple
of tricks from the 80s but if we glue
them together then and kind of
generalize them a little bit then we can
see that we get that we get we're able
to estimate in an embarrassingly
parallel way interesting properties of
of like giant deep neural networks the
there's a couple of other kind of things
that we can do here that are sort of
interesting to think about so one thing
for example is to observe that when we
do this randomized power series so what
we're literally going to do just to
describe the actual algorithm I'm
suggesting so you decide on what what
function you'd like to apply your
eigenvalues you come up with your
favorite power series for it and by the
way just as a sort of like one note this
thing only converges if X at the
operator norm of axes within the radius
of convergence of the original analytic
function or the original power series so
you come up anyway you come up with the
power series that you care about and
you're going to now you're now going to
draw from your proposal distribution get
a random integer draw an X that you're
going to that you're going to do hashing
vector product respect for products with
hit it J times and then you're going to
compute the inner product with your
original back with your original X
that's going to give you a scalar that
you then weight with AJ and divide by
and divide by the by the probability
that you propose that J that's not an
unbiased estimate of
of the result okay so like I said you
could use this so if you were if you
were willing to call approximations to
indicator functions for example a
analytic function or you were willing to
write down a sort of like a Tempe shove
approximation to something like a
function maybe that looks like this
so modulo things like the Gibbs
phenomenon where you sort of wind up
with walkie approximations near the edge
then we could ask questions about we
could count how many eigenvalues are in
this epsilon ball and so if we think
that small eigenvalues are sort of
interesting or the number of small
eigenvalues is interesting or like near
zero is interesting for the hardness say
of a of an optimization problem okay the
other thing to observe is that I talked
about how what we're going to do is hit
our random we're going to hit our random
X with our matrix a bunch of times but
when we hit it a bunch of times that
means that actually we're computing
we're doing all the work of computing
all the intermediate terms out to some
point and the and so what we could do is
actually come up with a different
version of this in which what we
actually do is not sort of the vanilla
important sampling thing but we observe
that we're going to have a randomized
truncation and we correct
just like with important sampling but
with the probability that we would
propose that truncation okay and this is
this is like very familiar to the sort
of numerics community in the way people
have thought about this previously
because there you would say okay well I
wanted to do this then I like the
convergence rates of chebyshev
polynomials so I'm just gonna run out to
some to some point and then that's where
my error is going to be right well this
lets us do also truncation but by making
it a random truncation then now we get
an unbiased unbiased procedure and maybe
maybe I mean and and it's not so much a
value statement about whether or not
you'd like to have sort of like high
profitability type errors or unbiased
algorithms but depending on your taste
and what you want then then this is a
kind of a way to do that by two random
and the downside is it turns out
surprisingly that if we so let me just
write that out sorted to make it to make
it clear what what I'm actually
proposing so if we were to do so if we
do this we're choosing an integer and
jumping to that point in the series and
then just choosing that one term in the
series for our hole approximation but if
we're doing that with the whole sequence
of matrix vector products then we might
then we're going to have done all of the
intermediate work to get there so we can
so we can kind of do the right
correction to use that hole to use that
whole sequence and that basically looks
like this where our new estimator is
going to be basically instead of just FX
we're now going to actually have a sum
up to whatever whatever sort of integer
we drew let's say it's K of the AZ Rose
are sort of the AJ's divided now by the
probability that we would have of all
the sort of times we're going to hit
that thing
in case the proposal so it's the same
proposal distribution but if you think
about it so now you're drawing an
integer and the question is how many
times are you going to hit you need to
account for all the different times you
would hit say propose like item number
three in the series on the way to item
number K right and so if you sort of add
that up then you always hit the first
one and then with probably one minus
probability the person you hit the
second one and so then you can sort of
like correct for that and now you can
see that you have this like randomized
truncation where you're correcting for
where you truncate like the probability
it would truncate at that particular
location certainly speaking it seems
like this should always be better but it
turns out that this does not always have
lower variance than the naive thing and
I don't have yet sort of interesting
results on like when exactly you would
always do this instead so there's a
couple of tricks for estimating what I
think are kind of like hard problems
that I hope will help us do the science
of asking questions about like 10
billion parameter models and help us
understand understand they're sort of
you know their properties will be better
ultimately leading to a better
theoretical understanding of these
things as well as kind of interesting
again interesting questions about graphs
interesting questions about quantum
systems and other things and 90% of what
I've told you here is not is not new but
it's an excuse to tell you about two
tricks that I think are really fun so
thanks for listening
we have time for some questions I want
to also add Thank You Ryan Ryan stepped
in spontaneously when there was a
last-minute cancellation we are extra
gratefulness it's very riveting so we
have Tom perk up what yeah big matrix
and if they want to compute this rate
you can always do it using an open deck
that's right so that's kind of that's
true yeah so that's a this is a good
point so just a so the the so everybody
can hear so you could calculate the
trace by by doing ten billion orthogonal
vectors right but the hope is broadly
that we can that will get much lower
variance is much sooner right then then
doing that but we can imagine worst case
scenarios like the one you described
earlier where really there's just sort
of like some sort of spike living out in
the matrix somewhere and maybe we won't
see it unless we do that so yeah so
there's there's two different things
going on so one of them is the
convergence rate of this kind of thing
which is which their variance pounds
depending on properties of a that
wouldn't be able to recite for you now
but that but that is this is like
relatively well studied and then there
is the very flexible sort of possible
range of good and bad outcomes depending
on F and what you choose what you
engineer as PI and and so there there's
like apps for which we would expect this
to convert or poorly right where the the
truth is that we need to see very many
you know very very many elements of the
sequence to to have a reasonable
estimates and this doesn't and I don't
have I don't have any condition to give
you for that right now but the and the
reason is because we don't generally
have these kinds of conditions for
important sampling but one can always
treat
I mean we can prove the variants per
spec for particular cases right but I
can't but I don't have a condition under
which will always work so like I can I
can you know I can derive the variance
for like log for examples and I'm
optimistic that I can derive their
variance for sort of like indicator
function type things but there's a lot
of that there's a lot of analytic
functions out there what does the
examples of datasets where you really
want to prove the case or some functions
of faith well so I mean the motivation
here it so is questions like argue like
how bad is your saddle point at some
point in optimization of a giant neural
network for time right I mean - I mean
you stopped training or maybe there is
some intermediate point in training and
there's a lot of sort of sort of folk
wisdom about what's going on with local
minimum or local minimum versus saddle
points and so on and the questions like
how do you validate any of that folk
wisdom how do you understand any of
these systems and asking questions about
these giant matrices is not something
that is like computing big tricks I
didn't see the connection that's good
yeah okay so we have this giant Hessian
and I want to know how many positive
versus negative eigenvalues I have more
much more sensitive right whether that
existing but we could ask that question
if we could write down an F that told us
that was counting the number of negative
eigenvalues
right because the trace of that will
count the number of negative eigenvalues
force
believe me well I'm not sure if this
function exists but know that I mean the
indicator function exists the question
is can we approximate it reasonably well
within to anyway we're happy with with
with the power series and the answer is
that people do it all the time but you
get this but the the penalty you pay is
this gauge phenomenon right which is
that if we approximate functions lakes
that have discontinuities then you wind
up with kind of like Wiggles right there
the edges
[Applause]